joining us now for reaction from boston
is jeff bt a retired delta force officer
who also worked as a counter-terror
official at the CIA in idaho former CIA
operative Mike Baker's with us and with
me here in Washington is Rosa Brooks a
former Obama Defense Department official
and current senior fellow at the New
America Foundation it's great to see all
of you Mike I believe you trained with
Gina correct so you can give us a little
insight into her and her experience you
demonstrated how what how duplicitous
the Democrats are and they supported
Brennan and now suddenly Gina Haskell is
a problem but Gina Haspel her work ethic
her experience who she is as a person
you know this well yeah we were in
training at the same time at the
beginning which seems like a long time
ago of our respective careers
she obviously has excelled where you
could argue mine with somewhat mediocre
but look I think what you should be
doing is taking this monologue the angle
and just putting it on a continuous loop
because it's absolutely correct the idea
that somehow they're able to now draw a
sharp divide between the confirmation
process for John Brennan what you'll
have a lot of respect for very well
experienced officer but you know unless
they have some different standard for a
male director designate and a female
director designate night I don't can't
imagine they do then how do you possibly
explain this other than as you pointed
out the difference is Trump and I found
most interesting of the open questions
that were asked yesterday in the open
session of the hearings were this these
questions about how did you feel about
it how you what did you think about it
well look what really counts when you're
talking about the Intel community and
the military and law enforcement is what
are the laws on the books at that time
right how somebody feels about it
frankly I don't care and I don't think
the American public really cares what
the fields are can you imagine if a
combat Brigade or your your operational
people and your intelligence community
go out and basically are making their
decisions individually based on how they
might feel about something
values question came up a lot Rose I
want to go to you because people who are
very critical of this president Phil
Mudd is a CIA analyst on on CNN and he
was asked about Kamala Harris's values
question to gina Haskell he said you
know did you think this is the this is
moral what was being done he she stayed
on the morality question this is what he
said do you believe that the previous
interrogation techniques were immoral
she spoke about her American values and
she spoke about rule of law I appreciate
what she votes on she can vote however
she wants I don't appreciate the
collective amnesia collective amnesia
obviously referring and again that is a
consistent critic of the president
collective amnesia on the part of
Democrats who voted enthusiastically for
John Brennan Laura I think you are
highlighting the fact that hypocrisy and
spinelessness are bipartisan vices here
I am disappointed in Gina Haspel I think
she didn't answer a straight question
and she owes us an answer to a straight
question do you think it's immoral she
dodged that one completely but you're
absolutely right that the Obama
administration soft peddled this issue
that were right we're now seeing
scrutiny and ask well I do think though
you're wrong about what dilemma it is
that Democrats are facing the irony here
is that Democrats like the fact that
Gina Haspel is not an ideologue she's a
professional she's not somebody who's
coming in saying I want to advance the
Republican agenda she's saying no I just
want to advance the American agenda
Democrats like that about her a whole
lot more than they like many of trumps
political appointees but the downside is
that if you want that you got to embrace
somebody who seems to have embraced
torture which Democrats aren't socially
former Delphine's is coming in on that
time challenged flag I've got to throw
the challenge flag there Rosa it's you
know torture is a propaganda word that
is a propaganda word and it's chosen to
evoke an emotional response it's chosen
to conjure up images of putting people
on the rack or cutting off fingers or
limbs let's go accurate propaganda now a
lot less law well if you train your
people Georgetown to
use propaganda terms you know you've got
to look I don't allow my students to use
loaded language like that let's talk
about what it is specifically it's not
the rack it's not cutting people's
fingers off or limbs off it is
waterboarding
so if you want to talk about
waterboarding let's talk about it let's
not go from the specific to the general
and the general is generally a lot more
heinous than what we're talking about
hold on I think what Rosa is saying is
there is a Convention Against Torture
right there's a UN Convention against
ever however we've shifted our
understanding of what that means and and
after 9/11 we wanted the information you
as your former commando experienced we
wanted the information to stop these
attacks and if any one of us had a kid
who was always been kidnapped and one
person knew whether our child was would
say do whatever you have to do to get
that information if there's parents we
know that yes you would know it's like
it's like having a pet dog and you train
the dog to bring the paper to you and
the dog does what you want it to do
follows your instructions and now years
later you beat the dog with the paper
you know it's like is it legal it was
illegal it was and she did legal
procedure and it was investigated twice
and found to be legal she's she's
eminently qualified to be CIA director
by any any fair indication or
examination of her background what she
feels as a person is frankly not
relevant to her to her job as a person
in charge of the tile and black site
that her feelings oh no does that mean
your feelings it's such a Democrat I
agree with many of the way I have to
what is your feeling I think Rosa first
is not my propaganda word after you know
there's a real irony here it's funny to
me how we always talk about the World
War two generation as the greatest
generation
so after World War two when we faced an
absolutely existential threat we
prosecuted in the Tokyo Tribunal's we
prosecuted Japanese soldiers for
waterboarding US soldiers and we called
it tortured then the same we've called
they we have called it torture consiste
Lee that's what the law calls it's not
what I call it there was a brief
period and the Bush administration when
some of Dick Cheney's team lawyers
decided they didn't want to call it
torture because they they wanted to be
able to do it that was then repudiated
just a few years later even by the bush
and Jamie still says we should be doing
at one time let me get to Mike first and
then we'll go back okay yeah I thank you
Laura yeah I can't believe that we're
we're going through this Andry
litigating again with somebody who's
this eminently qualified with this
position as as Gina Haspel is but look
what they did so well all those years
ago when you when you and this was a
front burner topic was the far left you
know they seized the Doug moral high
ground and said everything except
talking to a detainee is torture
everything now I understand it's a
obviously is an emotive subject but
frankly that's not the case there are
areas it's like everything else it's not
this or that there are areas and they
obviously refer to as enhanced
interrogation techniques that existed
that and may I remind you there was the
Department of Justice Office of Legal
Counsel you weighed in on this
repeatedly and clearly and unambiguously
and that would information passed at the
General Counsel the agency that was
disseminate to the field and if I just
point one other thing out there is a
warm path there is a well-worn path
between the Langley where the CIA
headquarters is and Capitol Hill back in
2002 2003 of briefers going up and
talking to the gauge on this program I
made that point ago they were they were
briefed Nancy Pelosi learned about at
the same time Gina did Jeff I just think
it's important here to recognize another
aspect of what you brought out in the
angle talking about that this is more
about Donald J Trump than it is about
Gina Haspel and even to the Republicans
involved in this I'm you know salute to
Senator McCain he actually encouraged me
back in the day to run for Senate which
I did I maybe I should be mad at him for
that because I got my clock cleaned here
in massive against John Kerry but you
know I have the highest respect for him
and everything that that he went through
but I think that he's letting his animus
against President
bleed over into this I mean you know he
has a strong dislike for the president
and when he says don't come to my
funeral that's a strong dislike and and
I'm afraid that he's so respected that
out of respect to him that other
Republican senators may accede to his
wish that this nominee of President
Trump not get confirmed and and I think
it's a mistake and I hope that he will
change his mind about and I hope that
his colleagues will recognize she's
professional it's like if you've got a
great group of people you want somebody
who knows how to best use them nobody
knows better than she had to get the
best out of the agency and we heard
today she's going to respect the law
guys we could have an hour conversation
about this and so many other intel
topics would love to have you all back
this fantastic conversation